[Music]
all right rocky in today's las vegas now
we're talking about
traffic if you're driving around you see
it a lot more cars on the road which
means
more accidents that is the topic of
today's la vegas now segment in which
i thought it was only appropriate to
interview eric from
my car so i guess it shouldn't really
surprise us when we hear that the number
of accidents is going up around the
valley
exactly as things open up again
schools are open uh commerce is starting
to
ramp back up so we see more cars and
more accidents on the roadways so what
can people do right now to be
especially careful when they're on the
road well they can
be aware of of their own feelings and
emotions a lot of us have been cooped up
for
a year maybe a little over that so
there's a lot of uh just
impatience we want to get there now
we're less tolerant when other people
don't drive the way we expect
them to drive maybe they slow down they
cut us off they don't wait
for us to go we see a lot of kind of
anger that causes accidents and fender
benders because people are just
not being courteous not being patient
stress levels are high
that's it what should people do when
they get an accident what are some steps
they should take
if and when well the the first step is
uh you know
take a breath we see a lot of people
getting out of their cars screaming and
just you know
looking for a fight just realize it is
what it is
it's an accident uh be as courteous as
you can be helpful if you can't to the
other person
yelling screaming that's not going to
help but it is important to take certain
steps
you want to call the police have them
come out assess the situation do a
report
and establish who's at fault who caused
the accident
and then you also want to get
information from the other party you
want to get a copy of the driver's
license
the registration card their insurance
card and uh it's always a good idea to
take video or photos of the cars
to show where how the accident happened
and also the damage to both cars
the tricky part i think for a lot of
people is when to call
their insurance company that's it a lot
of times uh
they talk to the insurance company as if
the insurance company was their friend
uh keep in mind they're always recording
the conversations and their goal is to
establish that you weren't seriously
injured in the accident
so a lot of times immediately after the
accident you have
no pain uh the adrenaline just
the whole shock of being in an accident
you don't feel that much pain you think
you're fine
so you can tell the insurance company no
i'm fine i'm not injured everything's
okay
and the next day you can't get out of
bed uh so then the insurance company
will say no you said you were fine the
day of the accident
you're either exaggerating or you were
injured somewhere else and are now
trying to blame this accident so it's
very important to
not talk to the insurance company about
your injuries talk to an attorney first
and we can guide you through the process
great advice as always to eric thanks
for joining us today
thanks kendall we'll see you soon i want
to point out i was safely parked
during that interview yeah for more
information you can give eric palacios
and associates a call
at 702-444-7777